[Music]
you
hey everybody so I've been getting a lot
of requests for who I think is going to
come back during season eight that we
haven't seen in a while
obviously I included Hodor in that
little teaser because of things that
Nikolaj coster-waldau has been saying
and that we're going to be seeing people
that we know with those blue eyes like
meaning the characters will come back or
be turned during season eight into
whites and if you are finding me for the
first time we do Game of Thrones every
week so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
stuff they didn't say who they didn't
spoil anything because they hadn't read
their scripts yet I feel like the
number-one pick should be pretty obvious
who would it crush you to see raised as
a white character that you've grown to
love now they could turn characters like
Cersei like Jaime it'd be big WTF
moments you know definitely go down my
top 10 list of picks four main
characters I think could fit that bill
but just remember that Nikolaj
coster-waldau said multiple characters
now he could also be talking about red
shirts in addition to main characters
but he's mostly implying about main
characters that you would see his whites
that you would never would have thought
about in that way before but of the
people that we've seen so far die in the
north because those are the only people
that the knight King is that access to
to turn into the army of the Dead the
biggest most heartbreaking one would be
Hodor because the last we saw of him was
probably one of the best episodes of
Game of Thrones of all time the episode
was named literally after the event that
gave him his name it was such a
heartbreaking twist and after that we
were just left to wonder what happened
to him now you could believe that benjin
circled back around and took him out but
there was a flood of whites that burst
through that door so I think obviously
we're meant to assume that Hodor was
taken down by them and what do they do
with their dead they don't rip them to
pieces they turn them into more fodder
for the army of the dead so here's my
list of other characters that I think
that they could turn into White Walkers
during season eight and obviously I
don't think they're gonna do this to
every character that dies even though I
do think that a lot of the main
characters are gonna die I'll link my
death predictions video at the end of
this - but right off the bat we have to
put the golden company's elephants at
the top of that list there at the top of
my death predictions list because how
cool would it be to see an undead
elephant walking around next to the
undead Giants and
still haven't found out if one one is
one of those because he was buried south
of the wall so technically unless this
was a vision of the future this has to
be some other giant that they took down
in the north but I've gotten so many
questions about beric Dondarrion in the
mountain because they've already been
raised from the dead through different
means
beric Dondarrion is a white raised by
fire as george RR martin explains it in
the mountain is a white that's raised by
a science so I know a lot of you did ask
me in my last video if the night king
could control the mountain because he's
Undead no I don't think that he can and
even though I do think that the Hound
will be able to take the mountain down I
think it'd be a little redundant to see
the mountain turned into a white
controlled by the night king and then
have him kill a bunch of people like
he's already doing that right now
it should go without saying that a large
portion of the northern armies in the
golden company anybody that goes to the
north and is sort of like a redshirt is
going to be turned into the army the
dead
without Cox you wouldn't find me
fighting in an army if I had no cook
barrack and Horman were status
undetermined at the end of the season
the wall came down but there are a
number of ways that they could have
gotten out either running the other way
across the wall in time or making it
down into a boat out into the bay before
the army of the Dead passed through the
wall either way I think they're fine
barrack is too important he's too
powerful to go down off screen in
torment is actually still growing out
his long beard the actor in real life so
you remember a kit harington hair watch
between season five and season six like
if he's not doing Game of Thrones
anymore then why is he keeping that long
hair why doesn't he trim it a little bit
but the same thing is now happening with
the actor that plays torment so as long
as he has that giant beard he is
probably still playing the character
meaning that he's coming back and he's
safe so even though logically he should
be part of the army of the Dead after
this big scene here I think he'll
survive
and he feels like one of those bran
characters that they make use of so well
like he just worked so well with the
other characters they did try to keep
him around as long as possible but I
know a lot of you been asking about Ned
Stark the people in the crypts at
Winterfell anyone who's died south of
the wall or anyone close to the stark
family has probably been burned by Jon
Snow so it will be impossible to bring
them back in the idea of Ned Stark
skeleton walking around swinging a sword
just feels too ridiculous but really I
think the main characters that are most
likely to be turned into the army of the
dead our people that are fighting on the
frontlines so like grey worm I think
that he's really high on the list of
potential people that the knight King
will turn because they've really been
pushing his character the last couple of
seasons but relatively speaking aside
from being the general of Daenerys his
armies is not that big of a character in
the grand scope I think like Jamie is
coming and he has a lot of those general
skills so anytime there's duplication of
powers the bigger character usually gets
favored so Jamie over grey worm grey
worm being turned into a white but the
real question I think is a priests of
the red God like Melisandre or even
Barrett could be turned into whites if
they were killed I think that Melisandre
could but it's almost like barrack is a
creature of pure fire at this point so I
guess there is a small chance because
you have to assume that if the dragons
are fired made flesh and they can be
turned into whites then if barrack is
just cut from that same cloth then he
could be turned into one too but if
there are gonna be any deus ex machina
then i just hope that he gets
incinerated by either dragon fire or he
himself bursts into flames by the power
of the red god before somebody could
turn him into a white so i know i'm
leaving you're on Greyjoy and some of
the other characters off the list that
are spending most of their time in the
South because Euron's gonna be ferrying
the golden company over and he's a
largely gonna be part of Theon story I
think Theon will get the pleasure of
killing him and if it happens that far
south and I think the chances of him
being added to the army of the dead are
really small so really after that all
you have is Jorah and like the other Red
Shirts that you might not remember the
names of that died in the last couple of
episodes of season 7 like all those
supporting characters that went north of
the wall with the Magnificent Seven that
ended up dying but I should add some of
the dire wolves to the list now there's
ghosts in Nymeria they're really the
only ones that are left it is because I
love ghosts so much I'll put Nymeria a
little higher on the list because Arya
just has that crazy bloodlust in Nymeria
is cut from the same cloth like they
share that bond so even though I'm
expecting with that 15 million dollar
budget for them to bring the dire wolves
back I think we'll see Nymeria added to
the army of the Dead and we should
actually remember that summer died
defending brand as they were trying to
escape from the tree so technically
summer should be part of the army of the
Dead too but let me know in the
who are the main characters you think
we'll see as whites
during season eight whether they died
last season north of the wall and we
haven't seen them since or though people
that will die in the north and the
initial battles like the people up at
the last hearth or the people at the car
hold but what'll happen is I'll do a new
Q&A video next week the Rick and Morty
finale is happening tonight so obviously
that video will post next but just leave
all your questions you want me to
include in that Q&A in the comments
below and there is a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber leave a comment on
the video congratulations to the winner
from the last video it's a trap please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight